pourquoi je crie
lundi dernier 20 diffusait le téléfilm
très attendu sur grégory lemarchal
intitulée pourquoi je vis g
qui es tu
un programme qui a beaucoup fait parler
a été vu par plus de 7,3 millions de
téléspectateurs
un film qui retraçait le parcours
singulier de ce jeune candidat de la
star academy décédé en 2007 des suites
de la mucoviscidose une maladie mise en
lumière grâce au combat des parents de
grégory qui depuis sa disparition ont
décidé de médiatiser le combat qu'a mené
leurs fils pour faire reconnaître la
maladie est une possibilité de faire
passer un message
c'est la raison pour laquelle pierre et
laurence lemarchal ont accepté la
production et la réalisation de ce
téléfilm si tf1 profiter de cette
histoire pour battre des records
d'audience
reste à savoir si ce téléfilm a
réellement profiter à l'association
grégory lemarchal alors biopic de
grégory lemarchal le téléfilm at il
servi la cause de la mucoviscidose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kevin d'accord avec le seul qui répond
oui face au téléfilm chez désolé est
compliqué de défendre je le cours quoi
c'est juste que je juste dans le cas du
téléfilm je les regardais comme tout le
monde
honnêtement j'ai l'impression de suivre
le parcours d'un jeune homme lambda
c'est le contraire c'est le m6 par
exemple ou là oui effectivement j'ai
ressenti beaucoup de choses ce téléfilm
pour moi était limite je vais grossir
les mots j'entends déjà être eu un peu
incolore inodore je m'attendais à
beaucoup plus que ça on en a on ce
concept ou déjà degrés dans les marchés
algériens n'avaient tutu déjà proposé ce
que indépendamment de la qualité uni où
le défi n'a servi la cause je n'ai pas
reçu de message le message donné de
l'argent par colin drones américains
avec le dock mais avec le biopic nom
mais dont le but que j'avais à rien non
le témoin j'ai demandé à hawaï la non
complètement on a une chair la cause
sera la cause à 200%
on parle de la mucoviscidose on parle de
l'association faut penser à tous ces
enfants où nous ses parents d'enfants
qui sont touchés et qu'ils ont besoin de
ce2 de se projeter justement de se dire
des enfants à qui on dit baye temps
parce que tu vas pas vivre longtemps et
puis ils voient des voix des films les
reportages comme ça ils voient
l'association et ses lueurs d'espoir
pour eux c'est tellement beau à 12
heures oui avec louis message et
services informatiques mans ça sert
automatiquement sur le biopic dont je
réponds par rapport au bio pied j'en ai
tellement vu aymen taha de voir un jour
ni ses onzièmes par rapport au biopic
qui a eu une telle émulation avec la
fait la promotion il me manque des fonds
pour moi du trou mais oui mais justement
mais ce que tu ne sais pas c'est qu'il
faut qu est ce que tu dis que les gens
connaissent la vie de grégory mais non
les jeunes ya plein de jeunes qui
avaient un pas qui c'est c'est ce qui
est important et ce qui est génial dans
ce biopic
au delà du t2 de la qualité ou pas c'est
que tout le monde est attaché à ce
personnage like du coup les enfants
regarder les grands-parents garder les
parents regardaient et voilà ça crée
quelque chose et effectivement le dock
encore plus important encore est très
important et on a découvert aussi ce que
c'était que le quotidien d'un malade
donc je suis désolé les compteurs ont
exposé par ailleurs mais c'est la sienne
mais bon ya pas de débat ça a servi ou
était inondé de messages comme la
réalité maintenant ce qu'il faut
absolument qu'ils arrivent c'est que tf1
reverse tous les bénéfices à
l'association pourcentage de confirmer
un paysage de tout faire de l'unité si
on peut pas de mélange fait une fois il
faut un téléfilm and co scénariste des
films de la série marc mais si on fait
ami l'a fait il ya deux jours spéciale
ils ont fait tout le temps des débats
est nettement l'argent le nom
d'association qui rêveraient de passer
ça mais c'est clair pour qu'on parle oui
sur moi quand j'avais fait la ferme
célébrités à l'époque ça c'est vrai j'ai
gagné c'était vous là bas
oui avec avec un marteau mais c'est moi
un petit chat ça m'enchante est pas
d'aller dans cette émission là mais
j'avais envie de faire connaître mon
adresse et sur les femmes c'est une
grande aubaine et j'ai gagné énormément
d'argent des droits mais aussi cinq ans
de mac est actuellement rédigé peu
importe le flacon pourvu qu'il y ait
l'ivresse
[Applaudissements]